then you get a mid-credits scene which
remember all those Woody Harrelson
announcements I don't even know much
about carnage but I thought it was so
corny it was not Arnage it was so corny
Woody Harrelson anytime in any kind of
wig distract it like generally speaking
up any dairy it was very coarse for sure
like I think true detective is an
amazing first season and Woody Harrelson
is great yeah but anytime he has hair
I'm like that's clearly away you know
it's so dark
not Woody Harrelson high reject nation
I'm Greg Alba I'm John Humphrey I'm
Tyler Minh Kyle
Yzerman from the fan three youtube
channel has just watched the awesomest
movie ever
venom mmm before we go into this review
I wanted to tell you guys thank you for
following us and start us up over there
we post reactions 30-second ones for a
TV show film or trailer as a matter of
fact take a look at her venom one guys
would you all join it yeah
let's hop into this review shall we
okay so this is gonna be a spoiler talk
and the way we want to handle our
spoiler talk is if you just walked out
of the film with us and so we're not
gonna do some like ultimate breakdown
with a movie we're just gonna talk about
it alright we don't really even have
notes prepared or whatever we're just
gonna speak what comes to mind there's a
couple of things that of course we have
to touch on because those are the of
course moments you got to talk about
right let's go right into this well I'll
just give our general thoughts this
movie gave me 100,000 percent what I
expected it to be I had been saying for
a couple videos now that at most this
movie is going to be entertaining
cheesy I did not think this was
necessarily a good movie I would say
though that I was definitely not bored
and I was very entertained throughout
and then overall actually like the film
like that's the funny part about it I
don't think it's a terrible movie but I
like it and honestly all the credit in
the world goes to Tom Hardy yeah you
could have a cool action scene here or
there but that would not save this movie
what saves this movie entirely from
falling apart and just being a terrible
film is the performance of Thomas the
Hardy John you go yeah I mean I think
you summed it up really well I feel like
this is a misshapen strange movie but
they're better made bad superhero movies
that I've enjoyed a lot less than this
one and yeah if there's anything to say
to this movies credit if you get one
thing right it it better be the most
important thing and this movie does for
the most part get Tom Artie and his
relationship with venom right and those
things keep this movie alive and fun
when it could have been a total disaster
Kyle is a huge spider-man fan who was
very much not looking forward to the
venom movie Oh Kyle I I was actually
planning on not seeing it at all it was
like it's not Marvel's spider-man
it's Sony's venom was actually
pleasantly surprised I went in with
really low expectations so it was better
than I expected it definitely like you
said was entertaining so if you're
looking for a movie that's entertaining
it definitely fits the mold if you're
looking for accuracy's or things that
make sense yeah then you're not gonna
find that in this movie I could I could
see a lot of people who really are
committed to reading those comics hating
this movie because it doesn't really
have a sinister tone Eddie Brock is very
different from my understanding yeah
very different because Eddie Brock in
this film is a really nice guy like yeah
yeah he is is smaller useful he has
these qualities in Michele Williams you
miss asked him about like you know
giving a psychoanalysis of how it's
terrible of a guy Eddie Brock is and I'm
like that ain't present in this movie he
seems like a really nice guy I think for
this film though it actually works
because you have the Eddie Brock
personality and a very different venom
personality and I'm also thinking with
Topher Grace which is the other recent
life adaptation that we got
venom he was an angry messed-up Eddie
Brock and then you got venom which only
amplifies that I thought it was kind of
cool to have the the comparison between
the personalities yeah that makes a lot
of sense I mean if we're gonna get on
board with this guy there's gotta be
something redeemable about him because
we're already altering a character
that's been a villain and and kind of
you know transforming into a hero's own
comics but yeah like for a movie and in
an introduction to a lot of uninitiated
people I feel like that's necessary I
will say in terms of comic-book
comparison he is much more accurate to
venom in this movie than he was in
spider-man 3 yeah not not at all but he
has a long way to go to actually be well
I mean here's how I overall feel of how
someone will enjoy this movie because I
hear a lot of criticism towards it when
we got out of the theater all this would
be something start I suppose we're all
you know that they didn't like the movie
the thing is I couldn't argue with them
I'm like you're right the difference is
I enjoyed that
thank you that being said if this was an
MCU movie I would have a very different
opinion that's the thing is that this
movie greatly weighs on what your
expectations are walking into it and
what you're willing to settle for coming
up yeah what you're willing to settle
for what you're willing to forgive about
this movie the first act of this movie
happens right very fast but very fast
very sharp
I remember thinking the editing was like
weirdly off when in the second scene
when they're having their date when Anne
and Eddie Brock are having dinner the
cutting was just like ridiculous and act
was in a big hurry and not only was the
cutting of that scene ridiculous it had
such terrible continuity with the takes
they were using I'm like you're using so
many different takes I was not looking
at Michelle Williams once in that scene
I just kept looking at Tom Hardy and
every time they made a cut he was making
a different facial expression from the
last day yeah yeah super distracting
it's either they just had horrible
chemistry or we actually ran to quit
John dro after the movie one of the
things he pointed out was he's basically
said like it's clear that the reshoots
didn't match with what they shot
originally which hampers a lot of their
chemistry so whichever take on that you
there's a lot off with that stuff I mean
cob what do you think of their chemistry
did you think they had any cuz I did not
no no no no it was hardly anything to
build off of it all their chemistry was
just the fact that I like both of them
their chemistry was we're in a
relationship I really do think Tom Hardy
saves this movie because I don't like
anyone else in this movie well I think
Riz Ahmed is surprisingly boring he had
a weird thing where I didn't think you
were lazy it's not a bad perform it's
just a dull performance yeah once you
get it you got it yeah he was very
monotone and at first they almost
introduced him like he's like a nice
person or something and he's like a more
sinister version of Elon Musk eccentric
that's how to pitch you him I didn't
really see the full character or
whatever all homework he did for the
role I don't really see where he's a
genius and I don't really see how he's
this charming guy who built his way to
the top I hated that Trump reference you
are fakeness one everybody single and
choice you makes in this movie you're
like how did you get to where you are by
being like I don't care about any
program and I think human testing yes no
and Michelle Williams was the most
upsetting part because often times with
roles like this you can at least walk
away going they didn't really get much
written for them but they did a good job
and here I was like you know Michelle
Williams character actually had more to
do than the average female comic book
character not that it was like good
written material but it really seemed
like she didn't care
yeah it felt that way I associate
Michelle Williams is one of the best
actresses we have today and then
watching her here I'm like damn dude I
would think you're a terrible actress
this is your first movie I was watching
it felt like her taking it easy like
there are moments where I was like I'm
sure but for the most part like when
they wake up out of bed you know what
she's hitting him with a pillow I'm like
oh god where the [ __ ] is the chemistry
that scene for the first time like that
morning yeah like is this it are you
guys auditioning right now yeah going on
I thought the writing overall was not
good but that's why Tom Hardy was the
best part of the movie began he took
what wasn't great and he made it not bad
because this film has that point where
he does his annoying interview with
Carlton Drake and then it does this
abrupt six months later thing which
which I thought was very strange when it
occurred and then that's when the movie
actually got interesting kicks in
because because I thought oh man it's
gonna be like this is gonna be rough I
thought it was gonna be rough to sit
through and then it got interesting cuz
I like seeing Eddie Brock where he's
really down on his well it doesn't look
like six months have passed first of all
it looks like this is two days later
they're the same except as a part yeah
everything about him is the exact same
but I like the nice guy Eddie when he
interacts with that homeless girl and it
gives her 20 bucks for a newspaper that
was a nice moment and I even like the
touch of when the guy who you see in the
trailer with a turd in the would moment
when he Rob's the Chinese lady and they
had that back and forth beforehand of
you know how he doesn't meditate and
everything yeah watching Eddie Brock
trying to bounce back I found myself
surprisingly like caring about I kind of
wanted he brought to have a comeback
here oh yeah we like him to bounce back
and despite how I felt about Carlton
drink me in a bland performance I at
least felt like yeah I'm one that he
brought to win yeah yeah once you get to
the finale and stuff you you are like
yeah get him you know yeah you do at
least get to root against him even if
you're not very invested in him the
ending though was really like over the
top like with CG and stuff to a point
where you actually couldn't tell who was
fighting who and where yeah prising Lee
underwhelmed by that portion
specifically because that felt super
undercooked
well it wasn't well done I just mean
they put in crappy CG like crazy to the
point where I had no idea what I was
even watching anything yeah but even
getting to that point cuz once it became
clear that it was the finale I was like
oh oh we're doing this now yeah I just
learned about this it takes away a lot
of the catharsis and a lot of the
beat-em-up tension from that scene
because it's like oh you both just
became big venom monsters and now we're
already fighting we're already wrapping
this yeah I mean I I kind of liked what
they were building up with riot more
than when we actually got riot because
there's this movie I saw forever ago I
think it's called fallen with Denzel a
guy basically he keeps transported from
body to body by touching them and he
could go in and out of it yeah yeah yeah
that's what this reminded me of what
it's like with the Chinese cop and the G
takes over the old Chinese lady then the
little girl and I kind of enjoyed that
element Jason goes to him because I
wasn't sure like oh is this leading Arau
I wasn't really trying to think ahead in
that department I like that little side
storyline so it's kind of a letdown is
when riot first shows up when you first
see riot yeah I was like whoa that's
actually pretty scary looking yeah and
then kind of just becomes whatever just
like a louder scarier venom I guess hey
you know because act 2 is easily the
best part of this whole movie and actors
like the most of the film I mean there's
some funny funky stuff but I was really
enjoying it even though I was
questioning that's what I mean this
movie really depends on you willing to
forgive a lot act 2 is where it feels
the most like an actual movie cuz the
first act is like super rushed and then
the third act is like a sliver and the
second act is where most all the great
stuff happens yeah
was when Eddie Brock gets his powers
like that was super predictable when
it's oh it's the homeless lady who she's
been kidnapped and she's being a test
subject that when she like latches on
him I'm like oh some flesh for horror
stuff I like origins tales of what
powers are bestowed upon someone without
them realizing I like that kind of
element the part that was super missing
and all that coolness you can't help but
compare this movie to upgrade if you've
seen the movie upgrade not just because
those two dudes look alike but it starts
to play out very similar to what Eddie
Brock like first he jumps off a wall and
pushes a guy dad I'm like I can see how
teenagers yeah going on shirts readily
yeah and then he like kicks open a whole
[ __ ] door
yeah oh my no reaction and then he jumps
over a fence then they jump through a
fence actually a dress through the fence
I'm like no like what's going on no
little not even a little sliver I'm like
I'm sure there's a finger shot right you
can throw that in there and
knocks over the tree the the big log but
even then he's just like help all right
moves forward from there
honestly I gotta get the movie credit
because there was a couple of really
good moe
like moments that were that was awesome
I loved the moment when Eddie Brock
comes home he's drinking the beers he
starts eating from the trash and then
he's in the mirror because you see that
moment in the trailer anything it's
gonna be like some super suspenseful
[ __ ] and he's in the mirror and the eyes
come out or there's another scene where
he goes and he finds Michelle Williams
and her new boyfriend at a restaurant
going looking super feverish and
freaking out and eventually just a cool
down he hops in the lobster that was my
favorite scene knowing on an actual live
lobster that was just good acting like
we say Tom Hardy elevates this I don't
mean it by he's so charming he elevates
it he's committed there's some real
emotional [ __ ] we learn he's like
confused and chaotic and panicky in that
restaurant he's like rude to everyone
around him and he's like hating people
and stuff that was hilarious even before
that though went like what you guys
think at the same when he meets the
boyfriend and I guess I was really well
done yeah right everything they did with
the boyfriend weirdly enough it reminded
me of Superman Returns the way you don't
hate James Marsden right it's kind of a
similar thing I like when they do that
when it's like the girls moved on but we
can't hate this guy and he also kind of
becomes a part of the plot like I didn't
like the way that unfolded where he's
trying to help him he's trying to get
him tested and yeah figure out the
medical side of this you know but yeah
when they show up in the uber and he's
like I'm a big fan of your work really
he's like people who seems like genuine
like yeah he rocks kind of a cool guy
yeah good good work you know and one
good line Michelle Williams had is in
that moment when she says I'm one of
those people oh yeah yeah that was a
genuinely funny moment I would you think
of the moment when all the bad guys
broke in he was into his apartment yeah
I I thought it was fun but I also didn't
not see that in the trailer yeah I mean
that was a big thing with this movies it
showed so
much of what we've already seen yeah I
mean there's very little that isn't of a
scene or a moment that you've already
seen in the trailer like you could
basically expand on all the ideas the
trailer gives you and figure out how
this movie's gonna go yeah yeah that's a
fair point I mean I still think they
went with the overall context it was fun
like in the trailer when he hits
everyone and then it cuts to the line of
why would we do that in the film he said
let's eat their head yeah then it was
funny yeah where is it a trailer it was
yeah yeah yeah no question like going
well of course he did they're trying to
do that but in the context I like that
the trailer left out the details that
venom is talking to him at that moment
he's not just like taking over his body
Venom's actually verbally in his head
when I gotta say I know I wasn't big on
the ending the finale fight but a lot of
the fights in this movie I thought were
pretty impressive too cuz that second
unit Direction is so visceral and
there's a lot of really punchy camera
angles you can see I was really actually
my favorite scene I really liked when he
was running through the woods I thought
that was a really cool super intense
yeah yeah it was it was just really
kinetic but not so much that you can't
tell what's happening and the movie
overall has so much good action like it
really does some of the moves and stuff
are really freaking cool to watch a
scene yeah that was so cool and even I
mean just just the back-and-forth
between Tom Hardy and venom you know
they're weird buddy dynamic oh there's
some weird lines for sure but I guess
that you know there are a few decent
ones as well venom does kind of a
character shift halfway through this
movie I mean there's so much enough
rewarding moments and like I said
smoothie hinges on so much forgiveness
because the second trailer is when you
get the venom revealed the official
reveal and then funny enough the
official reveal is like that in the
movie venom in some ways felt like a
genie to me like what do you want I'll
grant it for you like yeah what was
missing for me in the venom and Eddie
Brock Department was like weirdly I saw
why riot and Carleton Drake worked well
what the genius of Carlton Drake had the
money and everything he can provide then
you got the power and the invincibility
of riot
sense whereas as much as I adore the
chemistry between Eddie Brock and venom
I was kind of like other than the fact
that you keep telling me their host
compatible
what does Eddie Brock really bring here
for venom I don't understand where
that's really coming into play like they
break into the office you leave the
phone that's about it right yeah you're
left going what kind of match are they
other than happens other than a good
buddy cop duo yeah it just so happens
that your body's the right time yeah but
I why what what exactly is there to you
guys but I know I like a lot of the
really hearts of hearts even in the
scenes with Michele Williams where I
felt she was very flat there were
moments where Tom Hardy's performance
elevated that after she learns he's
venom or learns what venom is and all
that and they're in the car right back
in Venom's saying like you should
apologize for all those things like
there's something about those moments
that are that I thought were really
touching there was one trailer that they
put up right before this movie came out
and it was all just completely focused
on Tom Hardy the entire time they're
just like Tom Hardy's incredible in this
movie I really loved my performance that
I got to work with Tom Hardy because
he's the best part they just kept poking
the fact because that's actually
accurate he showed up for his executive
producer credit okay and then you know
like towards the end of Act two before
we get into foul I some weird [ __ ]
starts going on
she venom shows up for a hot second yeah
and then starts making out with Eddie
Brock and and what was weird to me about
that was did Eddie know that that was an
because he was just like [ __ ] I'm into
it six months man I mom want to hook up
with something why she just making out
with her the she venom moment kind of
seemed silly as opposed to something
that probably should have felt like a
cool nod to something there's actually
two she Venom's okay well it felt like
it was gonna it was supposed to be like
a cool nod is something like that but
instead of kind of felt you know and
that's when the venom shift was occurred
it was around that scene out of nowhere
venom
from your planet is doomed to I decided
I'm gonna stay he changed his mind
because he likes you changed me hey once
they share a little kiss together yeah
you know Venom's hard little hard melody
they say Venom's heart grew three sizes
that day well it's like the the venom
shift is more than just some random arc
venom had the whole identity of venom
starts to be totally shifted because he
has this line in there I was talking
about who riot is and then he says this
thing about a my planet I'm kind of a
loser
it's like a funny line but it completely
alters everything you think of venom at
that point yeah I'm a loser in my play
yeah like that's one of those elements
of this movie that pushes hard on the
boundary of silliness but that actually
very much endeared me to the movie like
I can see people hating that stuff yeah
I thought that was very very close like
you said rushed finale because I know
where they're launching a rocket and I
was like oh [ __ ] we're like towards the
end of the movie it was that weird thing
of do I really want more of this movie
this also feels that rough this movie's
like a New York Deli sandwich where act
1 and 3 are like thin pieces of yes this
movie gets forgiven a lot for like
convenience II you know like how and
knows how to work an MRI machine
apparently or when the rocket is
blasting off and then she turns on the
thing like Oh her first time with these
controls and she knows how to do that
the vibration go off my girlfriend
pointed out why didn't why don't you
just like have the thing to deactivate
the rocket if she knows how to work that
baby I was like bouncing Drake slash
riot like slaughters the entire crew and
I'm like don't you need some people to
help you launch this rocket yeah reason
you have a bunch of people in this very
room
I'm sure the comic book fans out there
can explain to me further on how certain
things work and how sort of things don't
when the airplane is passing by Terry
and they have a [ __ ] they be around a
rocket ship like that confusing as like
wait a minute I don't understand what's
going on whatever on fire yeah sounds
like this seems like a crazier thing
than a plane
yeah
it never seemed weird when venom was
talking to Eddie but it seemed weird
when Eddie was talking to venom like in
terms of Wayne is yeah when venom was
informed that Eddie was talking like
that seemed strange to me the moment
that also confused me but I thought was
a neat effect at the time but then it
could infuse me later Eddie looks into
the car and he sees the reflection and
then he sees venom wait a minute though
you don't control his mind
are you altering what he's seeing I get
this is there some kind of like weird
overlap between your minds where you see
some of what venom is is that very
selective I'm confused I mean they rules
though makes they actually do do that in
the comic books a little bit and I think
it's more of an artistic thing than
anything that part didn't bother me but
what did bother me was that they really
artistic they they very much seemed like
completely separate entities instead of
slightly merged together they were
always attached to each other for the
most part Eddie never really became part
of venom no he's a roommate like it
makes for great comedy dynamics but
there's that moment that just plays a
super cheesy after that crazy venom riot
fight where riot was slightly built up
to be this insane threat but did it play
out that way yeah get to see that man
I'm like I mean other than the fact that
I was kind of confused by what was going
on in the fight I was like venom seemed
like he was handling the [ __ ] pretty
well actually like the only thing you
get to build up riots menace is just
that one scene where he kills a bunch of
regular people who have never seen this
before and then fights venom the venom
is even saying like he's a leader we
have a zero percent chance we have a
deer but when the fight happens I'm like
you see what you're doing amazing a
little bit behind got a few more combos
and weird maneuvers what I've realized
is that venom just needs a self-esteem
boost because he's got a lot more
potential than you realize
no benhams kind of turned into like a
comedic character in this movie yeah the
part that I thought was supposed to play
out like a like a meaningful moment
so and riot stabs Eddie and then he has
the spike through his heart and then
Eddie reached has his hand out then you
see the symbiote crawl up venom and then
as if it's this like no there was
nothing dramatic about it him both seams
cord yeah felt like that was supposed to
be one of the few moments in the movie
where your bucket moved there should've
been like a pause or even a cut to
another scene first or something would
have known some kind of drama there yeah
there's no tonal nuance around it at all
it just feels like another moment in a
stream of moments the only part like
this movie has a weird shape because to
me you like it starts down here and then
it goes on this big hump and then it
kind of middles out still like the
beginning and ending parts don't have a
pace they just have a fast kind of
chopped yeah I don't know a lot about
riot but I would say that it is a
letdown regardless because I thought the
way they were building up riot was cool
and then when you get riot I'm like eyes
is kind of whatever thing at this moment
you're supposed to believe that I mean
obviously no one believes that venom is
dead
like he sacrificed himself to save Eddie
which is ridiculous and I thought it was
gonna end on a note oh man it might be
gone now but then you see look at
symbiote right so they had this moment
where Michelle Williams Tom Hardy are
talking with each other you hear his
voice yeah and I actually love that like
that was a moment where I was like
that's funny like that was cool because
I didn't see that coming she says some
comment about like I'm sorry about venom
and he's just kind of trying to brush it
off and to me I'm like and I really feel
like I've heard that moment for him to
feel like he's missing venom
yeah but then for to reveal venom is
actually in there like little does she
know you know I thought that was a
really cool moment and then come to find
out the next five minutes are all shown
in the trailer yeah certain the winch is
the Saudi trademark juice show the
I really liked that they divided that
idea up into two different scenes where
you get an intro and at first year they
play with your expectations but then you
get so far into the movie you're like oh
we haven't seen that scene yet I was
honestly sold that moment in the trailer
where he's were only gonna hurt bad
people like I thought for watching the
trailer that would occur in the fun and
games part of act 2 so by the time we
got to the finale I thought that scene
was just cut out of the movie and like
they showed us the deleted scene in the
trailer
weirdly that didn't bother me because
the way it played in the movie I thought
worked better than what I anticipated it
would play originally I'm like okay this
is kind of cool then it's kind of funny
then figuring out how they're gonna you
know like you can't just eat everyone's
head and by the way you do see someone
said get eat it bit off which I thought
was surprising cuz I thought oh wow I
wasn't actually expecting to see that
because of all this r-rated not
happening stuff and it's heard of the
whim part happened what was weird to me
about that was how Eddie Brock handled
the situation after he did that in the
trailer I took it as he kills that guy
and then the trailer showed us a
different moment when he's talking to
her and they just slice it together to
make it look like the same scene and
come to find out oh that's all in the
same scene this is kind of weird this
leaves a whole bunch of questions for
that poor Chinese Li you you traumatized
her she has questions what if someone
comes looking for Eddie you're just like
yeah parasite is funny right how do you
know she's gonna be cool this is it the
MCU you probably scared the living [ __ ]
this is new / yeah everyone was very
nonchalant about most of the things that
were happening in front of them one what
about like I didn't think about this
during the movie but like there are a
few of those fights that are very out in
the public so like what about all the
other people who just could have seen
that the villain was so reckless in the
movie overall yeah like I just couldn't
get over how much they were just causing
utter destruction and chaos throughout
the city and there was no ramifications
or no concern to a TV screen about like
who is this mystery accurate yeah
like that then you get a mid-credits
scene which remember all those woody
harrelson announcements I don't even
know much about carnage but I thought it
was so corny it was not managed it was
so corny
Woody Harrelson anytime in any kind of
wig is distracting it like generally
speaking any dairy is very coarse for
sure like I think true detective is an
amazing first season and Woody Harrelson
is great yeah but anytime he has hair
I'm like that's clearly away no it's so
dark not what do you hear
but this wig especially because it was
vibrant orange almost it hasn't even
read really it was orange already
Michelle well there's had a pretty awful
wig but I could rest and then here I'm
like there's no way you know more with
that thing and then I'll gonna see his
Woody Harrelson too and then when he
said that line up that last line there
would be a lot of carded Oh God like I
don't I didn't there were so many things
in this movie that I didn't even care to
roll my eyes at but that like I'll even
allow you little little cheeky things
like that but that was so on the nose
that yeah I mean Kyle as a fan of the
comics would you think of the carnage
moment it was literally not carnage at
all yeah it couldn't have been less like
carnage it was like they painted a
halloween version of him like from a
kid's outfit and we're like you're
carnage now yeah like I'm no great
carnage expert either but the second he
showed up I was like this is not what I
this not what I've seen in any of the
venom we talked about this with a
theater and honestly like the actor who
plays the Joker in the Gotham series
would have been great and Ramona Hanna
yeah or the war dude who almost played
penny wise when Poulter yeah would have
been fantastic
or the dude who plays penny wise might
as well Woody Harrelson didn't come off
to range he came off as Woody Harrelson
trying to act Orange the a post-credits
scene gives you the actual genuine this
is great yes which is
essentially a giant movie clip it isn't
to the spider it was a mini movie right
there yeah it wasn't to the credit it
wasn't even on one minute scene it was
like wow we just got like almost a
substantial chunk it was great and that
was great it was amazing it was like wow
this looks amazing I'm stoked to see
that movie that looks great but what it
did open the door for that it got me
thinking about because it says meanwhile
and in another universe which I thought
was clever as opposed to meanwhile on
the other side of New York you don't
have to worry about is this venom world
exactly connected so having the universe
thing is kind of a safe bet for Sony
because in some ways if Marvel one day
was like you know what we could do it
now oh you can do a universe thing so
many things through this side yeah yeah
and then redo the whole organ right I
mean theoretically do whatever you could
go there's a different venom universe
where it's still Tom Hardy but it's
slightly different and slightly better
yeah yeah overall I had a lot of fun
watching the movie I wouldn't say it's
by any means a great movie there are
times where I can tell what is like bad
intentionally or unintentionally bad I
feel like when Tom Hardy's not on-screen
I thought it was kind of dull but
whenever Tom Hardy was on screen and
that's majority of the film it was very
entertaining overall I would say like
lower the expectations and you might
enjoy it yeah yeah I agree with that one
under cent because I had the lowest and
I came out really liking the movie I'm
actually probably gonna buy it but just
so I can drink - yeah yeah yeah it is a
fascinating movie because yeah I mean
this movie is just as much a mess in a
lot of ways as everybody probably has
prepared you for by now but Tom Hardy
just makes it so lovable and so
enjoyable and yeah the fact that he is
so much of the movie really does save
the just the viewing experience like I
said at the top there are better bad
comic-book movies but I would so rather
watch this sooner than a lot of those
it's not Sony's worst superhero movie by
I'm shot I would rank this right above
amazing spider-man 2 and right below
spider-man 3 yeah that's like I prefer
this venom a million times over Topher
Grace's man yeah yeah 100% but in terms
of the movie alright probably watch
spider-man probably more quality moments
in spider-man 3 but I think you would
probably have more fun watching venom oh
yeah oh yeah it's also a leaner movie
Tiger it's fun in the audience claps
they did yeah I wasn't even just a
couple people yeah and I would say the
end credits themselves were pretty cool
with the mmm but then they played the
song might run the jewels yeah which I
was like guys those are our thoughts
thank you for watching if you made it
all the way through you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification bell cuz he now
subscribe but every youtuber say Oh Kyle
on the fan theater YouTube channel what
do you do reactions to over there a cop
we mostly watch content that already
exists like Buffy supernatural and now
Doctor Who but we sometimes do trailer
reactions all kinds of fun stuff coming
good stuff there and make sure to
download falls in the Stardust at people
link in the description box
[Music]
[Applause]
you